die kinder gehen da draußen ganz
unbedarft mit dem thema um aber da
draußen lauern tatsächlich gefahren denn
so wie es im moment aussieht bedeutet
das eine katastrophe sind noch zu viele
menschen draußen auf den straßen und
heute ist der letzte tag wo wir jetzt
noch die kurve kriegen können wir müssen
zu hause bleiben ansonsten wird unser
gesundheitssystem zusammenbrechen und
das ist wirklich eine katastrophe darum
wird heute gehen und ich werde zeigen
dass ich doch übrigens mal rausgehen
kann unter ganz speziellen bedingungen
also klicks um science fiction die
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktivierte glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's diese
bilder haben mich dann doch etwas
erschrocken von fern airbag der übrigens
zwei coole vegane kanäle hat unter dem
könnte den deutschen abonnieren und ja
diese bilder bedeuten es sind zu viele
menschen noch unterwegs sie halten nicht
immer den abstand und jeder der das tut
erhöht die zahl der korona infizierten
einfach statistisch und das bedeutet
dass wenn wir nicht sofort damit
aufhören das deutsche gesundheitssystem
in etwa 678 tagen komplett
zusammenbricht wir müssen jetzt die
kurve kriegen und warum das so ist das
rechne ich am ende des videos mal vor
ja ich kann nicht rausgehen aber ich
kann doch ausgehen unter ganz bestimmten
bedingungen
ja das ist die einzige chance habe ich
bekommen mit der nacht setzte kurz vor
mitternacht die straßen sind leer
einfach irgendwie distanz zu einer
leuten zu halten und das nutze ich umher
buchmann bisschen luft zu schnappen
es ist schon ein bisschen gespenstisch
leer hier aber das macht mich auch
irgendwie sicher dass ich hier keinen
menschen begegne und und den abstand
halten kann ja gestern vorgestern
vorgestern hatte ich ja noch so ein
solches breakdown
heute bin ich total euphorisch ich weiß
nicht ob das was hier mit der isolation
zu tun hat dass man irgendwie so
komplette stimmungsschwankungen ab hat
ich bin echt kein typ für
stimmungsschwankungen
aber es passiert so viel positives wir
haben wahrscheinlich die möglichkeit
gefunden dem grafik hat er jetzt echt
keine aufträge mehr hat mit dem super
kanal zu machen also ich mach ich
dokumentiere zeichnerisch workshops und
eben auch konferenzen also wirklich
große meetings ich hatte jetzt eine
veranstaltung in estland für mehrere
tage die wurde gecancelt
und das ist ja die chance jetzt für dich
wenn wir da einfach 1000 prozent geben
also hintergrund ist mit christian
planen wir schon lange einen wissens
kanal und ja wir sind kurz vorm start
jetzt in diesen tagen sonst passieren
ich hatte noch idee dazu und das machen
wir da hab ich jetzt erlebe darauf
angesetzt und sich noch darauf an wir
machen direkten patrick otto kenzler
patrick ja aber das passt ja in deiner
situation perfekt ja ja das optimale ja
auch alles grau also dann kann ich da
ich mein ich habe jetzt ja da wird's
inspiration ich habe jetzt
jetzt läuft es bei mir auch heiß und ich
hab themen über die ich was machen wir
also was also super es ist perfekt
und so soll es dann aussehen durch das
corona virus saß kauf 2 und die
berichterstattung darüber begeistert in
der letzten zeit ein bestimmtes wort
durch die medien pandemie wir sind
erwähnt worden bei grimme online award
und das spricht vielleicht gibt es ja
eine nominierung das finde ich schon
toll aber noch erwähnen im block ist
schon mal richtig geil dann die
geschichte mit arte dass die reportage
machen wo das videotagebuch reinkommt
[Musik]
heute morgen war montag früh
aufgestanden weil ich freitags immer
sechs videos drehen muss für meine
kanäle ich dann musste ich mich für
einen kollegen der youtube kanal oder
ich für zwei kollegen die youtube kanäle
haben die sich um cannabis und drogen
kümmern
mit youtube telefonieren das hat ein
bisschen gedauert weil die ständig
videos von denen löschen dann habe ich
mit der medienaufsicht also der
medienanstalt berlin-brandenburg
telefoniert um dann ein bisschen druck
zu machen dann hab ich das habe ich ja
noch was habe ich denn noch spülmaschine
habe ich ausgeräumt also echt nur tolle
dinge obwohl ich ja alleine zu hause bin
und da muss man sagen was für ihre
möglichkeiten die digitalisierung bietet
also ansonsten würden wir wahrscheinlich
wirklich die decke auf den kopf fallen
aber ich bin mal gespannt wie es mit
meinem gefühl so weiter geht ja
eigentlich ist das ganz einfache
mathematik es geht um eine exponentielle
funktion und die bedeutet dass es nicht
eine feste zahl an fällen ist die ist
mehr gibt pro tag sondern einen anteil
das heißt du warst ein viertel oder ein
drittel so zwischen einem viertel an
drittel steigen die korona fälle jeden
tag und das heißt es wird werden immer
mehr mehr
und das kann man hochrechnen wir werden
in 78 tagen etwa die grenze von 40.000
neuerkrankungen am tag überschreiten und
das sind zu viel
aus einem ganz einfachen grund 5 prozent
der infizierten müssen künstlich beatmet
werden müssen auf die intensivstation
und wenn wir 40.000
pro tag überschreiten was in dieser
frist passieren wird dann bedeuten diese
fünf mehr als 2.000 patienten 2000
patienten das aber genau die zahl die
die intensivstationen jeden tag
aufnehmen können und 2000 entlassen sie
nämlich dann auch an patienten weil die
behandlung auf der intensivstation von
kogit 19 etwa sieben tage dauert das
alles ist sehr grob aber einen tag mehr
also einmal mehr als 40.000 es ganz klar
es kann nicht funktionieren
das heißt heute ist wirklich der tag
heute ist schluss heute dürfen wir
niemanden mehr anstecken und das heißt
bitte bitte bitte keine sozialkontakte
mehr bleibt zu hause in den familien
geht wirklich nur in notfällen raus geht
zur arbeit zum arzt zum einkaufen eben
aber ansonsten bleibt zu hause
harald esch hat das fantastisch
vorgerechnet das video findet ihr hier
kriegt unbedingt drauf das ist wirklich
extrem beeindruckend und bleibt zuhause
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran